we have a voicemail number the number is
two one nine two david p i kind of like
this question because it's a
straightforward question about the
November election yeah David
this is Michael from Monroeville Indiana
and I just wanna know how likely is it
Trump will win twenty twenty election
yeah I mean listen okay I love it's a
simple question there's no answer this
so so when I talk about polling and a
lot of the polling looks good for Joe
Biden right now doesn't tell us what's
going to happen in November
ultimately November is going to be a
referendum on Trump specifically with
regard to the state of the economy in
the aftermath of coronavirus and it and
it may not actually be the aftermath
right we may be in a continued very long
first wave we may be in a second wave in
November I don't know
but ultimately we don't know Trump very
well could get himself reelected if the
perception is coronavirus is gone at
least for now in late October early
November if Trump can propagandize the
q3 GDP numbers as I suggested earlier
today that he will if Trump can say whoa
look at this start of a recovery
beautiful GDP numbers in q3 ignoring the
disaster that was q2 he can get himself
reelected for sure and if it's close
it's much better for Donald Trump to get
pushed over the edge in just a couple of
states the way he was in 2016 with
Hillary Clinton so my message is look at
the polls from an educational
perspective and make sure that no matter
what the polls say no matter what state
you live in you recognize that you must
vote we all must vote or we are going to
be dealing with another four years of
this insanity I hope you'll join me on
the bonus show today we will talk about
what's going on with the in-person
Republican National Convention we will
talk about insulin and the president's
recent focus on it we will talk about
Republicans suing to stop the move to
allow remote votes in the House of
Representatives something that would be
great to put in place all of those
stories and
on today's bonus show get instant access
by becoming a member on my website or by
becoming a patron at patreon.com slash
david pakman show